This video is brought to you by
Skillshare,
a wise crack.
Jared,
again,
are you one of the million spending your
evenings as a digital dark elf,
shotgunning strangers in the world's
most popular video game,
or if not,
are you wondering why everyone won't
shut up about the fluorescent cartoon
version of Pub g?
Whether you're a fortnight fan or not,
you might have a more pressing question.
How the hell was this free game making
billions of dollars?
You might think you know the answer,
but here's something you might not have
considered for night,
isn't making money in spite of the fact
that it's free.
It's making money because it's free.
Also,
it's stupendous.
Success might aluminate one of the
fundamental tenants of the modern
economy,
so climb off your Air Force One and
button up your virtual bridges as we
break down the economics of fortnight.
For those of you living under a
pixelated rock fortnight is a battle
royale style shooter where you hunger
games or weighted the finale in hopes of
being the last cat standing.
You can also play in squads or 50 slash
50.
It sets itself apart from the other
battle royale games with it's more
colorful and cartoonish style and the
ability to build things like a murderous
minecraft.
Oh,
and also everything is free.
The game is free to download.
The weapons are free and you don't even
need an inexpensive console.
Since you can play online on a potato.
This essentially makes the game
available to everyone with access to a
computer,
but fortnights producer,
epic games is making staggering amounts
of money.
In May of this year alone,
they made $318,000,000.
That's enough for Elon musk to launch
five rockets to space.
In other words,
it's a ton.
Not surprisingly fortnight,
makes its money on in game purchases.
Usually it's in game currency vbox.
We're going to assume the V stands for
virtual,
not vapid,
vacant or vacuous because what does this
virtual cash gets you?
Bad ass weaponry to slay your foes or
super powerful armor to protect you from
the bad men trying to teabag you.
Nope.
You know what?
You can buy dances and shiny things,
functionless armor and different
characters.
In fact,
you can buy all the bad ass,
silly or individualized you want,
but it's all purely cosmetic.
We all know lots of games manipulate us
into buying things.
It pays the payer with a skimper game
loop.
Use Lots of flashing into things and
condiments to make the player feel good
about themselves.
Train the players to spend your
currency.
Offer the payers away to spend real
currency for your picker,
and so they'll forget that are spending
money and make the game about waiting,
but let the player base,
not the wheat.
It's a surefire way to make lots of
money.
That's not news,
but fortnight is different than other
free to play games where you can buy
stuff that actually you know helps you
in those games.
Free to play is essentially paid when
why?
Wait 20 hours for your fortress to
upgrade.
If you can speed it up for ninety nine
cents,
but fortnight insists on equal access to
all players.
Even if you suck,
oh my God,
okay,
this is that.
This is better than another.
Really,
dude,
making sure that none of the purchases
actually give you any advantage,
which even if you hate the game is
pretty cool,
so why do people buy this stuff?
That's only function is cosmetic,
but we all just idiots trying real hard
to turn reality into an episode of Black
Mirror.
Well,
laugh all you want,
but our fortnights show boaters are
actually just doing something that we
all do,
whether we like to admit it or not.
It's basically just the logic on which
our whole economy is built to understand
why people want to spend their money on
books just to spend those bucks.
I'm a pick that's shaped like a baseball
bat.
We need to hop on a battle bus and
transport ourselves to the year 18,
99.
Back then most economists were trying to
figure out how the markets worked based
on how useful goods were,
how much labor went into making them,
and of course the supply and demand of
those items.
Economists essentially believed people
would rationally ordered their purchases
based on need.
You buy bread because it feeds you
coats,
because they keep you warm at second,
but then they looked at how the wealthy
were spending their money and thought
what it turns out.
People were buying the 19th century
equivalent of bunny brawler or ginger
gunner skins except probably filthy
engaged you smallpox or something.
Then along came economist and
sociologist Thorstein veblen tomato
discovery.
That might seem obvious today for
Veblen.
You can explain these irrational
purchases by recognizing that people
don't just purchase for utility.
They also purchase basically just to be
cool.
You might call this the snob factor and
economics,
but he gave it a different name.
Conspicuous consumption Bebo,
and recognize that people purchased
certain goods and services in order to
publicly flex their wealth and what did
veblen observed the wealthy doing to
show us their Mad Moolah?
The ceremonial differentiation of the
dietary basically really,
really expensive.
Boone's along with servants,
huge houses and cars,
all the poor had to get by on bread and
water.
The ability to consume and even waste
set the wealthy apart because what says,
I'm special more than literally throwing
or drinking away your cash or in a more
metaphorical sense,
stealing your mom's credit card to spend
hundreds of dollars on viva.
You have spent a bunch of panels on
playstation.
I can't believe you have done this.
Okay,
you've done this before.
Without this conspicuous consumption,
our modern economies might not even
exist if the economy just fed us,
clothed us,
housed us,
and gave us medical care and all the
today,
the economy would grind to a halt for
companies that always need to increase
their profits.
How do you squeeze a few more dollars
out of a coat?
Well,
you slap a designer's name on it or you
jack up the price.
To attract those obsessed with status
fortnight is maybe one of the most
impressive examples of the digitization
of conspicuous consumption.
You can set yourself apart.
Irl is you spend hundreds of hours
playing video games.
Nobody can see your sweet cakes or
vineyard bind swag and when all eyes are
on you,
once you've made it to the last two,
don't you want to leave an impression,
but for night does more than just
scratch a digital age for behavior.
We see everywhere around us in fashion
and cars and houses because it takes
this idea of conspicuous consumption and
gamifies it.
Mobile Games have the benefit of a
massive piles of data which allow them
to optimize your spending night
employees.
These techniques which are now common on
ecommerce sites and mobile games like
limited time offers with countdown
clocks.
That really reminds you how much you'll
regret.
Not taking advantage of this deal in the
next 13 hours,
but what sets fortnight apart is its
babbled pash structure.
Let me explain.
So if you're a regular player,
each season you can level up up to 100
times getting the occasional skin glider
tag or now toy,
but it's not every level and as you a
free player,
get the seat.
Oh Man.
Four levels.
I'll look like the red skull crossed
with ne more the submariner,
but you'll also see side by side all the
things you're missing,
vbox and XP bonuses and costumes.
You get the idea and at the bottom
there's a nice little reminder that if
you spend 10 bucks on the battle pass,
you could unlock all these things you've
already earned,
whereas some games might offer loot
boxes to manipulate you like a casino
drawing you in with a dopamine hit from
the luck of the draw fortnight draws you
in with pure conspicuous consumption.
Everyone else with a series of ebooks is
going to have this emote.
Do you really want to be the lead
without it,
and of course you can earn vbox by
playing the game and completing
challenges,
but that'll just take too much time and
set you apart as the poor kid,
but you might be thinking conspicuous
consumption is for the rich or at least
little tay.
I don't even have a park.
People dropping money on fortnite aren't
necessarily loaded well for veblen.
Just because conspicuous consumption
starts with the rich doesn't mean it
ends there.
If the rich want to show how important
they are with the things they own,
the poor want to escape the stigma of
poverty by appearing rich,
and then once the poor have successfully
emulated the rich,
the rich need to buy more equally
useless things to again distinguish
themselves.
Veblen called this depressing cycle of
economic epn waving pecuniary emulation.
In this way,
fortnights battle pat system works a lot
like fashion magazines.
Anyone can afford to peruse the pages to
see what high society is wearing,
even if they can't afford the clothing
itself,
but that's okay.
In fact,
it's the point you want the audience as
large as possible so that everyone
regardless of well can spot your $50,000
and this is how fortnight makes money by
playing on our desire to meet at least
as cool but preferably cooler than
everyone else.
What better way to earn money than my
making a game free to everyone so that
nobody feels left out,
but then providing incentive for folks
to pay to demonstrate their awesomeness.
Like I said,
the game isn't making boucoup bucks
despite the fact that it's free.
It's making money because it's free and
does it work?
Let's look at some stats.
In a survey of a thousand fortnight
players,
68 point eight percent had spent an
average of $85 on the game.
All the bids on cosmetic stuff.
Why?
Because it's all about keeping up with
the Kardashians,
so it's four nine really doing anything
we don't already experienced in our
analog lives,
not really.
They've just found the shiny new digital
arena in which we all want to be liked
and feel special,
so free or not,
we're totally by now.
Next time you need a break from the
world of slurp,
juice and boogie bombs,
skillshare has got you covered with over
20,000
wide ranging classes.
Want to learn a new language?
There's a class for that.
Want to get in shape?
Skillshare can teach you how want to
create your own video games.
You can finally beat your stupid friend
David,
something.
You can study entrepreneurship,
Hustle,
turn your game into a real business.
You can take these staples of branding
to make your game a huge hit,
and best of all,
you can take the fundamentals of
portrait photography so you can take the
perfect picture of dave at that exact
moment.
He realizes how successful you've
become.
Take that,
Dave.
Skillshare is premium membership,
gives you unlimited access to high
quality classes,
unmosque know topics so you can improve
your skills,
unlock new opportunities,
and do the work you love.
Join the millions of students already
learning on skillshare today with a
special offer just for wisecrack
viewers.
Get two months of skillshare for free.
All you have to do is sign up through
the link in the description or go to
[inaudible],
l dot ssh slash wise,
crack 12.
The first 500 wisecrack fans and sign up
will get their first two months of
premium for free.
Thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video and thank you all for watching
except you gave piece.